qui les regardent qui les aiment le
scorpion la médiane ou l'escargot arrive
au zoo de thoiry au sein de larges des
petites bêtes
le public va partir à la découverte de
70 espèces d'amphibiens et d'invertébrés
très souvent menacées d'extinction mais
pourtant si nombreuses
quand le grand public pense à la
sauvegarde de la biodiversité y pense
aux éléphants et pense au rhino et pense
au grand bao qui et puis on ne lui un
petit peu les petites bêtes mais elles
sont extrêmement importantes
c'est un maillon essentiel de la chaîne
à une inter et pour vous donner une idée
en fac hemani faire par exemple est à
peu près 6000 espèces et les invertébrés
ya un million trois cent mille espèces
au cours de ce voyage
on passe du rêve à la réalité de la
découverte des méduses aurélie sous la
mer aux espèces d'eau douce pour finir à
quelques mètres de là par la zone
nocturnes et ses espèces de la nuit les
espèces qui font peur les mygales les
scorpions et leur présence à un but
faire comprendre l'importance des bêtes
invisible j'aimerais que les gens en
sortant large réalise ce temps à quel
point son importante qui ces petites
bêtes et qu'en plus il se soit amusé
parce que ça c'est important
s'ils vont s'intéresser à la sauvegarde
de ces espèces
il faut qu'ils se soient amusés en même
temps et qu'ils aient vu comment eux
peuvent aider à leur échelle ne serait
ce que dans leurs jardins dans leur
maison pour protéger la nature
lors de ce voyage les visiteurs seront
accompagnés par nous et le prince de
larges des petites bêtes